Tasha: QA清单问答
Tasha: QA list Q&A
Tasha: 问答清单
Tasha: Q&A list
Jack: 你你你点开
Jack: You, you, you click it.
Jack: 在路景我第一次见
Jack: This is the first time I've seen it in street view.
Choiszt: 卧槽你这么多环境怎么会这样
Choiszt: Damn, with so many environments, how could it be like this?
其他人：没懂啥呀
Others: Don't get it.
Shure: 你是神吗
Shure: Are you a god?
Shure: 就是备份了一个
Shure: Just made a backup.
Shure: 然后直接点的这个import的就
Shure: And then directly clicked on import.
Shure: 对他正在装
Shure: Yes, it's installing.
Shure: 然后他装一会他就会报错开始
Shure: And after a while, it will start to report an error.
Jack: 我来学习一下
Jack: Let me learn a bit.
Jack: 以防哪天我需要copy
Jack: In case I need to copy it someday.
Choiszt: 不是你为啥不能直接重装呢
Choiszt: Why can't you just reinstall it directly?
Shure: 我忘了哈哈哈
Shure: I forgot, haha.
Shure: 我忘了我就是忘了
Shure: I forgot, I just forgot.
Jack: 就是就是
Jack: Exactly, exactly.
Jack: 你忘了你以前装过啥
Jack: You forgot what you installed before?
Shure: 我以前装过啥
Shure: What I installed before?
Shure: 我全忘了
Shure: I forgot everything.
Nicous: 不是我觉得你还不如现在先装
Nicous: I think you might as well reinstall now.
Nicous: 然后看他就是缺什么库
Nicous: And see what libraries are missing.
Jack: 你这样你是只要跑一段
Jack: This way, you just need to run a bit.
Shure: 我不是我就是
Shure: I'm not, I'm just...
Shure: 不是我就是
Shure: No, I'm just...
Shure: 哎呀怎么说呢
Shure: Ah, how to say it?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just...
Shure: 反正这个东西完全不是我自己写的
Shure: Anyway, this whole thing wasn't written by me.
Shure: 我当时就
Shure: At that time, I just...
Jack: 那你就缺啥你就造啥的
Jack: Then just make what you lack.
Shure: 行那我就
Shure: Alright, then I'll...
Jack: 不会有那么强的环境
Jack: The environment won't be that strong.
Nicous: 这不是想让你抽吗
Nicous: Isn't this supposed to make you smoke?
Nicous: 你他妈国家烟草的吧
Nicous: Are you from the national tobacco company?
Jack: 我用过所有库里面
Jack: Of all the libraries I've used,
Jack: 我觉得除了穿summer那种傻逼库
Jack: I think except for that stupid Summer library,
Jack: 前后不兼容之外
Jack: Which is not compatible front and back,
Jack: 剩下库对版本没有任何依赖
Jack: The rest don't have any version dependencies.
Choiszt: 我操确实穿summer
Choiszt: Damn, really, the Summer library.
Jack: 穿summer那条库真的很傻
Jack: The Summer library is really stupid.
Nicous: 我觉得那个opi那个谱音是傻
Nicous: I think that OPI music thing is stupid.
Jack: 我当时我当时写那个他
Jack: When I wrote that...
Jack: 不是那个他
Jack: Not that one...
Jack: 那些兰博荣耀不用fashion身身处嘛
Jack: Those Rambo honors don't need fashion involvement, right?
Jack: 嗯然后他两个版本之间fashion身身处
Jack: Hmm, and the fashion involvement between the two versions...
Jack: 就跟vivo fashion身身处那个kiwer不一样
Jack: It's different from the Vivo fashion involvement with that kiwer.
Jack: 然后
Jack: And...
Jack: 根本就没开
Jack: It wasn't even started.
Jack: 而且因为他是缠在那个COOX里面
Jack: And because it's tangled in that COOX...
Jack: 所以他不会报错
Jack: It won't report an error.
Jack: 他会正常跑了
Jack: It will run normally.
Jack: 而且他的速度慢两倍
Jack: And it's twice as slow.
Choiszt: 就是你根本没启动Flash
Choiszt: So you didn't even start Flash.
Jack: 但他不报错
Jack: But it doesn't report an error.
Jack: 你你你跑一个
Jack: You, you, you run one.
Jack: 你跑着看
Jack: You run and see.
Jack: 缺啥就行
Jack: Just see what's missing.
Jack: 缺啥装啥
Jack: Install whatever's missing.
Jack: 这个这个是一定是最快的
Jack: This is definitely the fastest.
Nicous: 就是给你重温一下巩固一下
Nicous: Just to review and reinforce it for you.
Nicous: 然后毕设
Nicous: Then the final project.
Nicous: 然后答辩
Nicous: Then the defense.
Nicous: 提问你你就能说了
Nicous: When they ask you, you can answer.
Choiszt: 谁他妈毕设
Choiszt: Who the hell asks about the final project?
Choiszt: 问你装啥库
Choiszt: What library did you install?
Shure: 我瞎他不也也也不知道我装的什么
Shure: I don't know what I installed either.
Shure: 环境
Shure: The environment.
Choiszt: 要对你自己负责
Choiszt: You have to be responsible for yourself.
Shure: 你滚我以后我就他妈都不干这行
Shure: Get lost, I won't do this job anymore.
Shure: 你举报你
Shure: I'll report you.
Shure: 我举报你的
Shure: 你经常吗
Shure: You often do this?
Choiszt: 我全是自编的
Choiszt: I made all of it up.
Choiszt: 你举报吧
Choiszt: Go ahead, report.
Choiszt: 一一举报一个准
Choiszt: Every report is accurate.
Jack: 哈哈哈举报这些没用的
Jack: Haha, reporting this is useless.
Jack: 你必须要给显在那个系统里面
Jack: You have to show it in the system.
Jack: 举报他呀
Jack: Report him.
Jack: 就他有一个什么什么毕业险
Jack: He has some kind of graduation risk.
Nicous: 卧槽他那个写的就是什么伪交数据
Nicous: Damn, he just wrote fake data.
Choiszt: 我的数据怎么是伪造呢
Choiszt: How come my data is fake?
Choiszt: 那只能说GPT太不稳定了
Choiszt: That just means GPT is too unstable.
Jack: 他他他们是讨论的全部是0.2
Jack: They were discussing everything as 0.2.
Jack: 哈哈哈 0.2就是的
Jack: Haha, 0.2 it is.
Nicous: 没办法我就喜欢随机
Nicous: No choice, I just like randomness.
Jack: 他们这0.2套p等于0.5
Jack: They set 0.2 and p equals 0.5.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈这说的有道理
Choiszt: Haha, that makes sense.
Nicous: 哦这样不然我怎么改随机的
Nicous: Oh, otherwise how can I change the randomness?
Choiszt: 不是你auto都在这上跑吗
Choiszt: Weren't you running auto on this?
Nicous: 跑的inference啊
Nicous: Running inference.
Choiszt: 那这个怎么看
Choiszt: How do you see this?
Choiszt: 显就是整就是
Choiszt: It shows, just...
Shure: 它没有显存
Shure: It has no memory.
Shure: 你把那活动监视器打开就能看了
Shure: Open the activity monitor, you'll see it.
Shure: 不是他们俩不分你知道吧
Shure: They don't split, you know?
Jack: 16级对16+5啊
Jack: Level 16 versus 16+5.
Jack: 现在是不是18级
Jack: Is it level 18 now?
Jake:搞定了吗
Jake: Is it done?
Choiszt: 16级能跑个啥呢
Choiszt: What can level 16 run?
Jake:保定了吗
Jake: Is it fixed?
Shure: 没没搞定
Shure: No, it's not done.
Shure: 但是可以可以进行下一个活动
Shure: But we can move to the next activity.
Katrina: 是不是要让他们带一个自己的
Katrina: Should we ask them to bring something of their own?
Katrina: 二手物品啊
Katrina: Like a second-hand item?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Yeah.
Choiszt: 16级能跑啥呢
Choiszt: What can level 16 run?
Nicous: 你别照我的
Nicous: Don't follow mine.
Nicous: 你就照你的
Nicous: Just follow yours.
Nicous: 信任就行
Nicous: Just trust it.
Jack: 跑16g已经可以跑千万1.8g
Jack: Running 16g can already run million 1.8g.
Jack: 哈哈哈 16g的显存
Jack: Haha, 16g of memory.
Jack: 够跑千万1.8g
Jack: Enough to run million 1.8g.
Jack: 够千万1.8g
Jack: Enough for million 1.8g.
Jack: 是能够7米跑呗
Jake:还是没装上你
Jake: Still didn't install it?
Jack: 你缺什么呢
Jack: What are you missing?
Jake:你知道看这个数据集的人
Jake: You know, people who look at this dataset
Jake:一般都会装哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: usually install it, hahaha.
Shure: 我操太侮辱我了吧
Shure: Damn, that's insulting.
Shure: 肯定缺
Shure: Definitely missing something.